on
depuis tu les hommes existent le ciel et
le domaine du divin
mon
histoire de l'aviation
bon
oh
la conquête du temps l'ère du jet
les sensations procurées par le pilotage
sont très particulières c'est dû à la
position dans laquelle on les a la
possibilité de voir l'horizon qui
n'apparaît pas de la même façon que
lorsqu'on est au sol à la liberté de
mouvement a la possibilité de voir la
terre de haut en bas de base en voler
dans l'espace
c'est un peu comme regarder par une
fenêtre et voir passer une planète d'une
beauté incroyable
c'est une expérience personnelle d'une
richesse et d'une profondeur qui vont
bien au delà de la technologie qui
permet d'aller la roue
on
l'homme a effectué bien des progrès
depuis les premiers rêveur qui
regardaient les oiseaux s'élevait
majestueusement dans le ciel immaculé en
passant par de vinci montgolfier qu'elle
et les lianes talent par les frères
wright dans le sillage de rickenbacker
lindbergh doolittle et d'amelia earhart
sur ce chemin magique les visionnaires
de l'aviation northrop boeing et douglas
ont mis en place des lignes reliant les
quatre coins du monde les océans ont été
parcourus par des hydravions et des gros
porteurs
mais la conquête du ciel ne s'arrête pas
là elle se poursuit jusqu'à la lune et
au-delà
ce désir de voler d'aller plus loin que
notre environnement immédiat est quelque
chose de constant tueur je crois que
c'est un besoin instinctif chez l'homme
fondamental la curiosité le pousse à
aller découvrir ce qui se cache au délà
de son horizon je crois que la seule
limite est l'imagination de l'homme au
début l'avion était une curiosité puis
il est devenu un objet de fascination et
finalement une obsession depuis les
premiers vols d'attraction en passant
par les vols commerciaux jusqu'au vol de
libération qui ont eu lieu dans le ciel
d'une europe déchirée et celui du
pacifique pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
la seconde guerre mondiale devait
changer le destin de l'aviation à jamais
jadis affaires d'utopistes d'industriels
ou de casse cou l'aviation allait
devenir celle des états qui voulait
protéger leur territoire
dès le début de la guerre il apparut que
la supériorité aérienne serait
déterminante pour une victoire des
alliés sur les puissances de lax
l'amérique était entré dans la seconde
guerre mondiale avec les biplans encore
en service dans l'aviation militaire
elle termine à la guerre avec certains
des avions à hélice les plus puissants
jamais construits
il y eut une époque où l'on pensait
qu'on ne serait jamais mieux comme
appareils à moteur à pistons que le
mustang p-51 le mustang était un
ce fut sûrement le meilleur appareil de
combat jamais construit pendant la
guerre il avait un très bon comportement
à haute altitude et un basse altitude un
très long rayon d'action
il pouvait échapper à la plupart des
autres avions il était rapide
ils montaient très haut il était
confortable et sa puissance de feu
étaient redoutables jusqu'à ce que les
allemands sortent m 262 ne regardions
jamais en eau car nous savions qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas voler plus haut qu'on les
ingénieurs et les chercheurs avaient
compris que pour aller plus vite on
avait besoin d'un nouveau système de
propulsion l'air de l'avion à réaction
commença à la fin des années 30 sans le
savoir deux génies de la technique
l'anglais frank middle et l'allemand
hans von braun inventaire simultanément
le processus du moteur à réaction et les
allemands gardère l'invention pour eux
ils sur de nombreuses réussites ils
produisirent des appareils de combat à
réaction en grand nombre vers la fin de
la guerre nous avons commencé à
développer ce moteur après le vol du
gloucester 28 39 des britanniques en mai
elles ont fait savoir au général arnold
qu'ils avaient trouvé quelque chose qui
pouvait influencer à l'issue de la
guerre il leur a demandé de recevoir
l'équipe d'ingénieurs pour se rendre
compte quand ils sont revenus à
washington ils nous ont recommandé de
copé
et alors les britanniques nous ont donné
le moteur whittle et nous l'avons
transmis à la general electric l'issue
de la guerre était encore incertaine le
secret total sur le développement de
l'avion à réaction par les alliés
étaient nécessaires
l'accord que nous avions conclu
comprenait des mesures de sécurité très
strict les britanniques avaient une
telle peur des fuites de renseignements
qui nous ont imposé des mesures très
strictes mais nous n'avions pas le choix
pour toute la période allant jusqu'au
premier vol il n'y a pas eu une
quinzaine de personnes qui étaient au
courant de ce projet
nous sommes en 1942 dans une base isolée
du désert de californie
le premier avion à réaction américain
lebel xp 59 est prêt pour son premier
vol le colonel lawrence crédit était le
premier pilote militaire à monter dans
le cockpit
en ce qui concerne le premier vol il
faut savoir que ce n'était pas un
premier vol habituel
le système de propulsion n'était pas
tout à fait au point et légendes de
general electric était extrêmement pour
le faire courir aucun risque au moteur
elles ont limité sa puissance à 50% et
lors de ce premier vol j'ai dû prendre
de l'élan sur 4 kilomètres avant de
pouvoir décoller mais j'ai eu une
impression de calme au moment où l'avion
a quitté le sol avec un moteur à pistons
le décollage était le moment où les
vibrations se faisait le plus sentir là
c'était le contraire
bien qu'aucun des appareils de combat à
réaction construit en amérique n'est
combattu pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale il était clair que ce nouveau
moteur était le moteur de l'avenir
avec la défaite des puissances de lax
les etats-unis et leurs alliés
continuèrent de développer les appareils
de combat à réaction
afin de ne jamais plus se trouver pris
de court l'apparition de l'avion à
réaction était peut-être le progrès le
plus important depuis le vol des frères
wright
mais ces machines révolutionnaire exiger
des formes nouvelles qui leur permettent
d'atteindre la vitesse et l'altitude qui
étaient dans leur potentiel
au début les moteurs à réaction furent
adaptés sur les ailes existantes
perpendiculaire à la carlingue
cela permit à l'armée de disposer d'
engin puissant comme le shooting star et
82 lookheed
cette nouvelle génération d'appareils
pouvait aller plus vite et plus haut que
tous ceux qui les avaient précédés mais
ils se trouvèrent confrontée à une
nouvelle barrière qu'on avait appelé le
mur du son au delà d'une certaine
vitesse il devenait instable et avait
des problèmes de maniabilité ils
provoquèrent la mort de plusieurs
pilotes le mur du son a constitué un
gros problème pour les pilotes dont la
carrière avait commencé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale en 1943 44 45
nous nous étions trouvés confrontés à
ces effets au cours des combats aériens
une onde de choc se former sur
l'appareil et ils étaient ce qu'on lit
dans toutes les directions
grâce aux plans retrouvée en allemagne à
la fin de la guerre les ingénieurs
américain britannique et soviétique
incorporer la technologie de l'ale
embiez qui améliorera les performances
de leurs appareils
quelques mois après la surprenante mise
au point par les soviétiques du mig 15 à
elle en biais les américains sortir le
chasseur sabres f-86 ces deux appareils
puissants allaient s'affronter à maintes
reprise dans le ciel de la corée du nord
non
rio
vous
non seulement la guerre change à
l'orientation des recherches et la forme
des appareils militaires mais est lui
aussi un effet décisif sur l'aviation
civile c'était l'époque des appareils
quadrimoteur trans océanique
l'un des plus élégants et et le
constellation de l'ocs est il lui aussi
le décès 4 douglas c'était la réponse de
douglas a look in ces deux appareils
avaient été mis au point pendant la
guerre est conçu pour transporter des
passagers
avec la guerre il servir d'avions de
transport militaire
les états unis étaient sortis de la
guerre avec deux lignes d'assemblage
d'avions de transport qui tournait à
fond d'abord mise en service comme
avions de ravitaillement en vol dus qu'à
ses 97 le strato crise heures de boeing
baptisé de fraîche date se joignit à
l'élégant constallation de lookheed et
aux décès 4 de douglas pour former une
flotte civile inégalée dans le monde
avec un réseau international de terrain
d'envol construit pendant la guerre et
récemment refait une nouvelle ère de
croissance s'ouvrait pour l'industrie
aéronautique
les découvertes financé par l'armée
allait être mise au service de
l'aéronautique civile pour transporter
des voyageurs désireux de se rendre aux
quatre coins du monde
dès 1941 alors qu'en grande-bretagne ont
travaillé sur les plans du chasseur à
réaction vampire quelqu'un qui voyait
déjà plus loin
j'ai de havilland a dit vous vous rendez
compte que l'on pourrait doter
l'aviation civile des mêmes performances
que cet avion avec le comedd britannique
sorti en 1952
on entrait dans l'air d'un jet il faut
rappeler toutefois conduire retiré le
commettre après deux ans de service
seulement de la ville on s'est trouvé
confronté à un problème que l'on
prévoyait mais qui n'était jamais à part
l'usure précoce du métal ça leur coûta
cher il eu deux accidents dramatiques
les obligèrent à repartir de zéro
les autres compagnies d'aviation civile
ne se laissèrent pas décourager par
l'échec du comet et continuaient à
rechercher un avion qu'ils aillent
encore plus vite et plus haut à seattle
dans l'état de washington
une équipe d'ingénieurs et de pilote
d'essai à les faire avancer la conquête
du ciel d'un pas de plus vers le futur
en 1952 faisant un investissement risqué
d'environ 16 millions de dollars soit 25
% de la valeur de la société boeing pris
la décision de mettre au point un
appareil civil adapté à l'ère du moteur
à réaction ils baptisèrent leurs
prototypes dash 80
c'est le 15 juillet 1954 que le pilote
d'essai texte johnson et son équipe
effectuèrent le premier vol sur ce
nouvel appareil 3 ans et demi plus tard
cet avion véritable tournant de
l'aviation était mise en service c'était
le boeing 707 panaméricains des boeing
ont vraiment institué l'ère du jet en
1958 avec le boeing 707 le monde avait
les yeux tournés vers seattle mais aussi
vers de glace bien que le douglas dc 8
est à peu près un an et demi de retard
sur le boeing
douglas était encore un concurrent très
sérieux
le succès des avions à réaction n'est
pas nue qu'on le croit allant plus
grande vitesse mais au fait qu'ils
étaient plus économique
le moteur à réaction présenté un bien
meilleur rendement que nos moteurs à
pistons durant les années 60 et 70 le
transport aérien s'est développée dans
le monde entier les compagnies aériennes
avaient besoin de plus en plus d'avions
panamerican et boeing lancèrent le jumbo
jet un avion à forte capacité
le boeing 747
le 747 fut bientôt suivi par le dc10 de
mcdonnell douglas et le elles disent
11,2 lookheed l'industrie aéronautique
avaient fait un autre bond vers le futur
ces nouveaux venus avait une capacité
encore plus grande et un meilleur
rendement
mais il restait encore une question
pouvait-on les rendre plus rapides
certains ont cru que ce qui compte c'est
la vitesse
ce n'est pas vrai c'est le rendement
secondes mais certains concepteurs ont
voulu mettre la vitesse au premier plan
et c'est ainsi qu'est né le concorde
ils ont cru que le concorde
allez rencontrer un succès immédiat
simplement parce qu'elle voler et à deux
fois la vitesse du son
il permettait d'aller de new york à
londres en moins de 80 ils n'ont pas
pris en compte l'investissement énorme
il avait nécessité et qui le rendait
invendables un prix raisonnable
en l'espace d'une vie humaine la
technologie le courage et la
persévérance avait permis aux
conquérants du ciel de passer du biplan
monomoteur rudimentaire à l'avion
supersonique capable de transporter des
passagers à une vitesse deux fois
supérieure à celle du son si on regarde
l'évolution de l'aviation eu tout
premier vol des frères wright jusqu'à
on se rend compte que pendant toute
cette période on n'a jamais dépassé 950
km à l est puis avec l'avancée
technologique on a fait des progrès
extraordinaires en vitesse et en
altitude
c'est dû à la recherche et cette
recherche s'effectue signé la base c'est
la base aérienne militaire d'edwards qui
a été choisie comme site d'essai pour
les nouveaux prototypes les avions à
réaction
les avions fusées ont été testés à la
base d'edwards
le x1 belle qui était conçu pour être
lancés en l'air fut le premier avion
fusée a volé aux états unis
véritable mission accomplie avec le x1
aucun avion n'avait volé au-dessus de 82
% de dépêches du ce le 14 octobre 1947
chaque jaeger pris les commandes du x1
belle le glamorous glenys il souffrait
de deux côtes qu'il s'était cassé la
veille en tombant de cheval
c'était le neuvième essai du x1 quand on
lui demanda s'il était prêt il répondit
plus que prêt
finissons-en je ne me rappelle pas comme
d'un grand jour parce que nous ne nous
attendions pas à franchir le mur du son
c'est un passé de 80 % de la vitesse du
son à 84 % puis 90 pour ça et 94% à ce
moment nous avions rencontré un problème
spécifique l'appareil perdait toute
stabilité horizontal et il devenait
impossible à contrôler
heureusement le x1 avait été conçu de
manière à pouvoir changer l'angle
d'attac de l'aileron de stabilisation
horizontal et de toute la queue de
l'avion
c'est grâce à cet aileron de
stabilisation que nous avons pu
contrôler l'avion et atteindre mach 1
reste du monde a mis cinq ans pour
découvrir ça le truc de l'aileron ça
nous a donné une bonne avance dans le
domaine de l'aérodynamique une autre
barrière naturelle avait été franchie il
restait maintenant à savoir jusqu'à quel
vitesse jusqu'à quelle altitude et
jusqu'à quelle distance les conquérants
de l'air pouvait faire progresser leur
machine dans l'espace mystérieux qui
s'ouvrait à eux réussir à dépasser le
mur du son bras ouvert un nouvel espace
à partir de ce moment il n'y avait plus
de limite de vitesse
un autre prototype fut testé à edwards
le 20 novembre 1953
scott grosse field aux commandes du des
558 de la société double as at any mc2
faisant un pas de plus vers l'espace le
thé 558 nous a tous surpris
à l'origine c'était un avion à décollage
au sol propulsé par un réacteur est pas
refuser mais le lancement vol du xe
s'était avéré si efficace que nous avons
décidé de lancer le dé 558 en l'air ça
nous permettait de partir de mac 1,2 ou
1,3 pour atteindre mach 2 tout était là
nous avons eu de la chance d'atteindre
mach 2 avec cet appareil à edwards les
recherches continuent r les pilotes et
les ingénieurs poussaient leurs engins
toujours plus haut et toujours plus vite
en 1957 commence à la fabrication de ce
qui devait être l'avion le plus poussé
l'avion fusée x 15
le x-15 était l'aboutissement normal du
programme de recherche entrepris après
la seconde guerre mondiale
ce programme comprenait le développement
des x1 x2 x3 x4 x 5 x 92 et des des 55
80 et des 55 82 au début des années 50
nous avions exploré les zones
transsonique et les zones supersonique
passe le x-15 a été développé par ce que
nous pensions qu'il était possible de
faire piloter un avion fusée par un
homme on venait de mettre au point des
moteurs qui développait la poussière 32
tonnes
nous voulions s'équiper un engin piloté
par un homme avec ce genre de moteur
pour savoir ce qui se passerait entre mc
2 ou 3 et m'accepte c'est pour ça le
x-15 a été construit le x-15 établi de
nouveaux records de vitesse et
d'altitude clip night son pilote
volà à la vitesse de mach 6,7 soit plus
de sept mille deux cents kilomètres
heure lors d'un autre et c'est que
joseph walker à tennie l'altitude 207 km
ce qui prouvait qu'on pouvait sortir de
l'atmosphère terrestre en avion et y
revenir
les records que j'ai établi avec le x-15
étaient les premiers du genre c'était
grisant mais c'était angoissant
s'il ya des pilotes qui vous disent
qu'ils n'ont pas eu peur en faisant ce
genre d'essai ne savent pas de quoi ils
parlent n'ont rien compris à moins de 60
ans après le vol des frères wright à
kitty hawk
l'homme avait réalisé un autre de ses
rêves
alors que l'équipe de recherche d'edward
s'apprêtait à aller plus loin dans la
même direction
un petit groupe de chercheurs composé
d'allemands et d'américains du centre de
recherche redstone à 3000 kilomètres de
là à huntsville alabama étudier un autre
procédé destiné à envoyer un homme dans
l'espace
ce groupe était dirigé par werner von
braun qui prédisaient hardiment un
voyage sur la lune avant la fin de la
décennie
quand je suis allé redstone j'ai vu le
bureau d'un feu de bois je n'en croyais
pas mes yeux
j'avais l'impression d'être dans de
kroger soudan flash gordon
sur les murs des représentations
étonnante et solidaire une main sur la
lune et sow pour atteindre mars une base
sur des stations spatiales
il est certain qu'un conquête de
l'espace ressemble à ce que font blanc
avait prévu dès le début des années 50
je pense qu'il avait un sens aigu des
relations publiques et l'a dit un jour
pour obtenir le soutien nécessaire un
véritable programme spatial il faut
faire appel au public
et voilà que cet étrange et un de nos ex
ennemi est allé donner des conférences
au rotary et au kiwanis
aucun d'entre nous n'avait jamais fait
ça il fait bouger les choses
ce n'était pas dans la nature des
scientifiques de rechercher la
médiatisation ils trouvaient ça indigne
2e et d'explorer l'inconnu ses fins de
brand qui nous a ouvert les yeux
la compétition entre l'équipe d'edward
et celle de nice ville devint acharné
chacune penser qu'elle arriverait la
première dans l'espace nous aurions pu
aller dans l'espace en avion et non avec
un engin balistique
mais à cette époque nous étions entrés
dans la course pour être les premiers
est le moyen le plus rapide et le plus
économique
c'était d'utiliser une capsule parce
qu'il n'y avait pas besoin de faire de
recherche utilisé le problème était bien
sûr le retour dans l'atmosphère à une
vitesse très élevée la faible résistance
des matériaux posait des problèmes ardus
étant donnée la technologie de l'époque
et notre connaissance des matériaux la
technique du bouclier thermique semblé
les plus sûrs et plus prudente mais moi
si ce n'était pas le plus élégant
nous avons pensé que notre programme de
recherche sur l'avion était assez
structuré et était techniquement assez
avancé pour ne venait dans l'espace mais
ce fut un événement qui se passa à
l'autre bout du monde qui décida de
celui qui allait être choisi pour la
conquête de l'espace entre l'avion fusée
et le missile balistique en octobre 1957
depuis les plaines vendeuse du
kazakhstan l'union soviétique lança le
premier spoutnik
c'était un assemblage de fil et de métal
qui ne pesait que 85 kg
la mise sur orbite de cette petite boule
devait changer le cours de l'exploration
spatiale
pour la première fois de l'histoire on
avait réussi à rassembler assez de
puissance pour permettre à un corps de
se séparer de l'attraction terrestre
cette puissance avait été fournie par un
engin balistique à nez arrondi et sans
elle les services d'eisenhower dans une
réaction deux derniers espoirs face aux
russes séparèrent l'aéronautique et
l'espace
l'équipe qui travaillait sur les fusées
fut chargé de l'espace
la différence c'est que chez nous il y
avait quelqu'un dans les fusées nous ne
resterons pas là à les regarder partie
et la course vers l'espace était en
route avec comme objectif la lune
le premier vol de spoutnik avait
provoqué la stupeur
nous étions ce goût puis les soviétiques
ont lancé des engins les chiens aboient
le 7 octobre 1958 un an et trois jours
après le lancement du premier spoutnik
par les soviétiques naquit le programme
mercury l'amérique entreprenait ainsi
officiellement de lancer un homme dans
l'espace le prototype développé avec le
programme mercury n'était pas un engin
comme les autres je tiens girl avait
surnommée la boîte de conserve nous le
considérions comme le chaînon entre le
singe et l'homme il n'avait pas vraiment
les premiers pilotes d'essai de mercury
et gemini trouvé qu'il n'avait pas grand
chose à faire en comparaison avec les
pilotes du xk en avril 1959 cet homme
allait devenir les nouveaux héros du 20e
siècle
alan shepard john glenn guez grissom
scott carpenter ou ali chira gordon
cooper et dicks layton furent désignés
pour composer la première équipe
d'astronautes américains tout éco centre
devenu célèbre
j'étais lieutenant je pianote et un f4
comme pas mal de gars et du jour au
lendemain je suis devenu quelqu'un de
quasiment unique
nous sommes allés tous les sept à la
base d'edwards où nous avons rencontré
skotko c'est que j'ai toujours admiré il
nous a regardés de haut en nous disant
pourquoi elle est aussi célèbre
vous n'avez encore rien fait et c'était
vrai mais c'est comme ça que nous avons
été reçus ça nous a rapprochés
nous sommes devenus des frères et nous
le sommes toujours
nous sommes au début du printemps 1961 à
cap canaveral
les astronautes américains du projet
mercury font des paris sur celui d'entre
eux qui sera le premier dans l'espace
tout est prêt c'est une alliance
extraordinaire de technique et de
puissance pure la fusée attend sur la
rente numéro 5
pendant ce temps en union soviétique
iouri gagarine s'apprête à envahir le
monde le 12 avril à 9h07 heure de moscou
il est envoyé dans l'espace plus tard il
dira j'ai bien regardé mais je n'ai pas
vu dieu
wernher von braun dépité fit remarquer
que lorsque les américains arriverait
sur la lune il leur faudrait passer par
la douane soviétique
le vol de youri gagarine le premier vol
habité dans l'espace captiva l'attention
des gens dans le monde entier mais il
donna un coup de fouet au programme
américain les soviétiques venait de
battre les américains dans l'espace pour
la deuxième fois la première fois avec
le satellite la deuxième avec le premier
vol habité la presse et le public était
fasciné par cette course vers l'espace
et vers les mystères du ciel
la presse intéressant mais en fait nous
sommes devenus des roues simplement
parce que nous avons été volontaires
pour remplacer des chimpanzés
c'est tout je ne me considère pas comme
un héros pour autant nous en
plaisantions entre nous à cette époque
là nous recevions des télégrammes de la
spa nous demandant d'arrêter les vols
expérimentaux avec les sages
alors on a fait voler alan shepard il
n'aime pas trop le quitter
le 5 mai 1961
alan shepard s'envola de cap canaveral
sur le missile freedom 7 conçue par von
braun son vol sub orbital ne durera que
15 minutes mais shepard était le premier
américain à sortir de l'atmosphère à
bord d'une capsule un américain était
allé dans l'espace
l'amérique était plus que jamais
déterminés à prendre la tête de la
course vers la lune moins de neuf mois
plus tard le 20 février 1962
des dizaines de millions de
téléspectateurs pu revoir john glenn
monter dans le ciel à bord de la capsule
mercury pour effectuer trois révolutions
autour de la terre
le vol allait durer quatre heures et 55
minutes
glenn était le premier astronaute
américain à voir le soleil se lever et
se coucher à une distance de 320 km de
la terre
john glenn devint un héros national
de plus l'objectif initial du programme
mercury mettre un homme sur orbite et
aide à pain
après trois autres vols réussis par
mercury ce fut le tour du programme
gemini qui devait faire avancer l'homme
d'un pas de plus vers la lune après
mercurey et le vol de jeu par la police
engage à faire des maquettes un homme
sur la lune c'était un énorme gemini fut
une étape intermédiaire il y avait un
certain nombre de choses que nous ne
comprenons pas suffisamment pour faire
l'économie de ce programme gemini et est
donc une étape intermédiaire entre
mercury et un polo le programme gemini
n'était qu'une étape mais chacun des dix
veulent qu'il comportait fascinèrent
l'imagination du public
mais pas
des milliers de spectateurs regard des
red white sortir dans l'espace lors du
vol gemini 4 reliés par un cordon à la
capsule white reste à 22 minutes dans
l'espace
six mois plus tard en décembre 65 /
gemini 7 franck baumann et james lowell
établir le record de durée en vol dans
l'espace avec 14 jours et réaliser un
objectif initial du programme gemini
le premier rendez vous sur orbite avec
gemini 6 piloté par ouali chira et tom
stafford lors de ce vol sur gemini avec
cet effort nous avons rejoint gemini set
c'était notre destination des mini 7
tenter de prouver que la capsule pouvait
rester deux semaines dans l'espace le
temps qu'il fallait pour aller dans la
lune et revenir 11 jours 3 jours briller
les trois ou quatre sur place et trois
jours pour revenir il fallait que les
engins et les hommes tiennent pendant
cette durée mais rien n'était joué
cooper était resté 24 heures dans
l'espace sur mercury mais et c'était
tout et finalement le programme gemini
fut un succès total
la route vers la lune se poursuivaient
comme l'avait promis le président
kennedy
le projet apollo devait faire débarquer
un homme sur la lune avant la fin des
années 60
mais la question restait posée qui y
parviendrait le premier je suis une
période de compétition agents nous
essayons désespérément de rattraper
notre retard
je pense que nous y sommes parvenus avec
gemini et que nous avons même dépassé
les soviétiques à cette époque mais nous
craignons encore qu'ils nous battent
je m'en souviens comme d'une époque
d'incertitude avant même le premier
lancement d'apollo une catastrophe
allait frapper le programme spatial
américain le 27 janvier 1967 lors des
derniers préparatifs de ce qui devait
être le premier vol en portant des
hommes un incendie éclate à à
l'intérieur du module de commande tuant
les trois astronautes
gus grissom et dwight et rogers chez
fille
mais comme les autres tragédies de la
conquête du ciel cette catastrophe
allait renforcer la détermination des
autres astronautes a réalisé le rêve
qu'il partageait avec les victimes
à
après 4 vol apollo réussi préparant le
débarquement sur la lune
apollo 11 attendait pour s'élancer dans
l'espace et concrétiser le rêve ultime
de l'humanité le monde entier retenait
son souffle
l'espoir qui reposait sûr extrêmement
intense et kennedy s'était engagé à ce
que notre pays réussissent à faire
débarquer un homme mais l'amérique
n'était pas seul en course
alors qu'à paulo se préparait à l'unir
les soviétiques avaient déjà réussi à
poser en douceur sur la lune
un engin inhabitée le l'une à 9
nous ne nous doutions pas que les
soviétiques étaient même prêts à tester
un énorme lanceur dans le kazakhstan et
le temps diminué de passer nous
craignons qu'il arrive quelque chose qui
nous empêche d'atteindre l'objectif
à moins d'un événement inattendu nous
allions être les premiers à réaliser la
plus grande aventure de tous les temps
dans le domaine de l'exploration et de
la technique
nous avons arrêté le moteur vérifier que
tout était normal et un la plupart des
instruments de spa mais neil et moi nous
nous sommes regardés et je lui ai donné
une tape dans le dos à cet instant nous
nous sommes rendu compte que nous avions
réussi ce don humanitaire rêvait depuis
si longtemps nous avions la chance
d'avoir été choisi pour mener à bien
cette merveilleuse entreprise
quand nous nous sommes trouvés sur la
lune l'expression désolation magnifique
m'est venu naturellement
je n'y avais pas pensé avant mais je
trouvais qu'elle exprimait bien la
beauté de ce que nous avions accompli en
tant qu'être humain et en même temps la
désolation qui nous entoure et c'était
un paysage à la fois pittoresque et
complètement désolé que personne
n'aurait imaginé
pouvant être des fois dans notre cerveau
apprend la presse je préfère quand même
à notre retour sur le porte avions
nous avons pris une douche posée nous
avons regardé des émissions de
télévision qui avaient été enregistrées
pendant notre vol
quand j'ai vu les images j'ai dit anel
regarde nous avons tous raté ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui s'était
passé de plus important n'était pas là
haut mais sur terre je le dis maintenant
avec un peu de recul
ce qui est important c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans l'esprit des gens sur la
terre après apollo 11
il y eut cinq autres missions apollo sur
la lune à la fin du programme
en tout douze hommes avaient marché sur
la surface du plus proche voisin de la
terre le dernier en 1972 la course vers
la lune était terminé mais le rêve du
siècle n'était pas pour autant abandonné
avant même les derniers vols
apollo le projet des premiers pilotes de
fusées d'edward avait vu le jour
la navette spatiale
le 12 avril 1981 vingt ans après le
premier vol sur orbite de youri gagarine
comment ça le compte à rebours de la
première navette spatiale américaine
columbia
moi
la queue
venez
jean
les pilotes john young et robert crippen
s'élevaient dans le ciel à bord d'une
machine d'un type nouveau
développant une poussée de 3380 tonnes
à une altitude de 100 km columbia ceux
mis en orbite basse
puis ayant atteint la vitesse de mach 25
young et crippen se plaçait sur une
orbite plus élevée à 200 km et
commencèrent la première de leurs 36
révolutions autour de la terre
ces nouveaux records de vitesse et
d'altitude pour un appareil à elle
faisait écho aux paroles de chuck et
guerre pitt knight et scott grosse field
au dessus de la base d'edwards où devait
se poser la mauvaise après son premier
vol dans l'espace
le gars était en fait un avion spécial
le rêve des pionniers de l'astronautique
c'était de partir dans l'espace sur un
engin et de revenir sur le même engin et
la navette c'est ça c'est un engin qui
décolle d'edward ou de cap canaveral et
qui revient plus de 150 astronautes dans
le monde ont volé dans l'espace
explorant l'inconnu ce fut une
expérience qu'aucun d'entre nous
oubliera
le décollage est quelque chose
d'incroyable
c'est ce que je connais de plus
impressionnant non pas à cause de la
violence mais parce que c'est
complètement différent
on subit les vibrations violente pendant
les deux premières minutes jusqu'à la
séparation des propulseurs d'appoint à
partir de ce moment-là tous calmes on
est propulsé par les moteurs de la
navette extraordinaire de voler dans
l'espace
je ne suis pas sûr que les mots existent
pour la décrire ce n'est pas simplement
la sensation de ne plus avoir de poids
qui est étonnante
tout ce qu'on y voit nous renvoie notre
insignifiance
j'en garde le souvenir de quelque chose
d'extrêmement marquant est complètement
incroyable penser que des hommes ont mis
au point un engin capable de les mettre
sur orbite de les ramener sur terre avec
un niveau de sécurité relatif quand on
est en haut
on a l'impression que c'est normal et
lorsque l'on réfléchit à toute la
préparation à toute l'énergie qu'il a
fallait pour vous y amener c'est
étonnant étonnant que nous autres
petites créatures bête ayons réussi à
maîtriser l'énergie nécessaire pour y
parvenir
pour moi personnellement le vol dans
l'espace a été une expérience très fort
sur le plan émotionnel et psychologique
voire la terre comme très peu de gens
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en août eu
l'occasion
regardez la courbure terrestre se rendre
compte de l' isolement de la terre dans
l'espace
c'est le genre d'expérience qui marque
et vous inspire d'autres pensées ça m'a
fait réfléchir à la création et au
créateur d'une façon
que je ne m'étais pas imaginé c'est une
expérience très forte
les vols de la navette ont transformé un
peu plus la conquête du ciel en une
conquête de l'espace ils se sont aussi
révélés d'une grande utilité pour toute
l'humanité
ils ont permis de mettre sur orbite des
satellites de communication le télescope
hubble premier observatoire de la nasa
dans l'espace et de lancer des engins
d'explorations interplanétaire comme
galilée et magellan qu'ils nous
enverront des images de jupiter et de
vénus et grâce à elle des recherches
scientifiques d'une valeur inestimable
ont été effectués dont les résultats
bénéficieront à tout le genre humain
mais il ya eu aussi des drames le 28
janvier 1986 la navette challenger
devait emmener dans l'espace pour son
dixième voyage un équipage de sept
personnes parmi lesquelles se trouvaient
christa mac auliffe à qui on avait
décerné le titre de professeur de
l'espace 73 secondes après son décollage
de cap canaveral la fusée explosa tuant
tous les membres de l'équipage une fois
de plus des hommes et des femmes à ces
intrépides pour vouloir réaliser leurs
rêves ne s'élèverait plus jamais dans le
ciel une fois qu'il ait découvert
l'espace qui nous entoure ne peut plus
être ignorée depuis le début de la
création
l'homme a suivi son rêve de conquête
tout comme de vinci montgolfier kele et
les frères wright ont suivi le leur
l'humanité continuera l'exploration du
monde inconnu de l'espace
intergalactique
je crois que le destin de l'homme et
d'aller dans l'espace
l'homme a toujours été là où il est
aujourd'hui capable de terry sur mars
et je crois qu'il y aura je pense que
nous devons retourner sur la lune et
ensuite seulement d'aller sur mars en
trop j'espère que nous retournerons sur
la lune bientôt et que vous et moi nous
vivrons assez pour voir l'homme aller
sur une autre planète
je pense que ce sera marrant je pense
que pour un avenir prévisible il faut
d'abord lancer une station spatiale à
partir de là nous verrons si nous
pouvons aller plus loin vol vers mars
est moins vif qu'un début
c'est la contribution de notre
génération folle d'exploration plus long
qui pourrait aboutir
fascinant l'imagination
une rencontre avec d'autres mondes
la conquête de l'espace et fait du d'opi
d'espoir et d'opiniâtreté
elle nous rappelle que le rêve perdure
et vivra encore longtemps
pourquoi l'homme explosent ils ceux qui
l'entourent je vais vous donner une
réponse un peu simpliste n'est pas très
original on y va parce que c'est là une
lycéenne a misé en légende d'un dessin
qu'elle a fait pour la nasa
nous ne serons jamais si nous n'y allons
pas les êtres humains sont curieux de
nature
si nous n'allons pas voir nous ne
connaîtrons jamais la réponse que tu as
dit nous poursuivrons notre exploration
sans relâche et à la fin nous nous
retrouverons à notre point de départ
comme si nous venions pour la première
fois j'aime cette citation car elle a
deux dimensions l'exploration en quête
du savoir et le retour avec la sagesse
pour le bien de la planète